Don't have a boss be the
boss with a hello world.
It's so Raj and I'm going to show you how
you can build a profitable business on
your own using tensorflow, Google's
widely popular machine learning framework.
A couple of years ago,
deep learning started to outperform all
other machine learning models when given
massive amounts of data and Google saw
that it could use these deep neural
networks to improve its
services from g-mail,
two photos to search.
They built a framework called tensorflow
out of a need to let researchers and
developers work together on AI models,
best animate crossover ever and have
them scale to billions of people.
Originally it was made
for internal use only,
but they open sourced it
so now anyone can use it.
We can build a really simple
tensorflow model pretty easily.
There are lots of examples online
for say classification for example.
All of it comes out to just
under a hundred lines of code.
The pipeline generally follows the
pattern of preprocess your dataset.
Build the model,
then train the model in a training loop
to ultimately saving the train of model
file to your local disk.
As a binary file,
but when our model is fully trained,
will want to serve it to
our users on a server.
That way they can access it from the web
and that's where the tensorflow serving
library comes in.
Serving implements a server that runs
ml models and provides remote access to
them.
We can do common tasks like prediction
and classification of any provided data.
Server bowls are the
central abstraction here.
They already objects that clients use
to perform computation like a lookup or
inference.
It could be a single shard of a lookup
table or one machine learning model or
five of them.
Let's say we have a model that is trained
to detect fraudulent data in a bitcoin
transaction dataset. We call this a
source. Later on, as we get more users,
we retrain our model on a new version of
the data and therefore have a new model
with all new weight values.
The source will detect a new
version of the model weights.
It will then create a loader that contains
a pointer to the model data on disk
loaders, manage the lifecycle
of a servable the source.
We'll notify the dynamic manager
of the new version of the model.
This dynamic manager checks with
whatever version policy you've chosen and
decides to load the new version.
The dynamic manager will then
tell the loader that, hey,
there's enough in memory.
It will then instantiate the tensor flow
graph with all the new wade following
values.
A clients can then request a handle to
the latest version of the model and the
dynamic manager will return a handle to
the new version of the servable because
tensorflow has been available
in c plus and python.
It's been relatively easy to integrate
it into web frameworks built in those
languages like Django
for Python for example.
Recently Google released tensorflow dot
js which lets javascript developers get
in on the game as well. I'm just
waiting for Schiffman to go in on this.
We can use it to develop client side AI
apps where the data remains entirely in
the browser building. Draining all
of it can be done from the browser,
but think about a mobile architecture
for AI. If we want to build a mobile app,
we can have it use a server client
architecture where the APP will just send
data to the server,
have it perform a prediction there,
then retrieved the output
and display it in the APP.
But what if we'd like to do
on device predictions? Well,
we can use the tensorflow lite library.
It optimizes for low latency
and small model sizes.
There's also lets our app work offline
so we don't even need Internet access.
Once we have a trained tensorflow model,
we can convert that model to a
tensorflow lite file using the converter.
Then we can use that converted
file in our mobile APP.
This works for both android and Ios
devices with the available Java and Swift
Api. This one problem with tensorflow
though was that it was missing a crucial
feature that AI developers
wanted imperative programming.
What that means is tension flow offers
a defined and run framework where you
define a computation graph then run it.
But newer AI models,
especially variance of recurrent
networks change in size while training,
they aren't static.
So a defined and run framework is needed,
which is a gap that the popular Pi
Torch Library built by Facebook filled,
but even then tensorflow
recently implemented eager
execution that gave it it
that capability as well.
In addition to all of these tools,
there are helper libraries built on
tensorflow for a variety of application
specific use cases from genomics
to music generation. Okay,
so all that is to say that tensorflow
offers developers a toolset that gives us
an end to end AI pipeline to build
an AI as a service business with.
But the question is what kind of business
should we build AI assisted Brazilian
waxing. There are lots of potential
industries ripe for disruption.
Let's pick two that I'm particularly
passionate about. Energy and education.
When it comes to energy,
climate change is a massive problem.
The amount of co two emissions globally
is far exceeding what it should.
The ice caps are melting,
entire ecosystems will suffer and
this is bad for all of humanity.
How can AI help prevent this problem?
If we look at it from a macro scale,
it seems almost impossible
for a small startup to solve,
but if we zone in on one small
solution that would help us get started
somewhere.
We know that climate change could cause
severe weather patterns like hurricanes,
higher temperatures,
and rising sea levels.
What if we could predict
where the riskiest and most
vulnerable regions we're on
earth for these severe weather conditions?
We could then help local
governments prepare for the impacts.
We could also use AI to improve the
energy efficiency of machines like
thermostats, irrigation systems,
trains, roller coasters,
anything really that uses energy.
Imagine energy like a grid
with multiple endpoints.
Each end point being a different device,
needing energy.
We can hard code in certain rules for
how and when and how much to power each
end point or we can optimize it.
We can build an algorithm that powers
each end point just as much as necessary
and not more so that it functions while
using as little energy as possible.
I like this use case and it'd be easier
to sell to businesses that specialize in
this sort of thing. Then governments, oh,
and ideally we don't have to build a
hardware solution since softcore alone
would be much easier to deploy.
So farms use a bunch of systems to
maintain their crop harvest. Howdy doody?
Yeah, John Smith. Okay.
Maybe we could build a system
that learns from crop yields,
energy amounts and weather data to
route data in the most efficient way for
farmers who powered their
crop maintenance subsystems,
which would save them money in
a way they couldn't. Otherwise.
If we could build a
solution for a single farm,
we could scale it to more later.
We could find a local farm,
ask them for their Dataset, and this
case it would be their energy bill.
The most basic version of this would
be to say optimize just one subsystem,
the one that waters their crops. If it
rains a good amount in the next month,
they shouldn't have to power their
automatic watering systems as much,
which would save them money.
We can train a neural network
on a combination of past
weather data and energy
usage and use it to predict how much
power to give the system next month.
All right.
Let's do one more education or advocacy
own in Espanol Si how cultured I am.
There is a trend towards democratizing
education that's currently happening
because more people are getting access
to the Internet and startups offering
online educational content.
How could AI help further this
goal of educating humanity?
There are a huge number of teachers
out there willing to teach,
but they don't always have the resources
they need to help students learn
grading administrative tasks.
These are basic things
that can be automated.
A full stack solution for teachers that
lets them do what they do best and have
the hard stuff automated by learning
algorithms would enable more teachers to
teach full curriculums online.
What's narrowed down?
Individualized supports can be costly.
For example, I get more requests for help.
Then I alone as a person can handle.
Ideally,
we could train an AI on my past data and
build a Saroj AI that could just answer
support requests just like I would.
A support Bot would be a great
example of Ai for education,
so let's go with that.
To find our niche.
Let's pick a single subject and
focus on that. Say Calculus,
we'll find a data set of
calculus questions and answers
or create one ourselves
by pulling from the web via an API.
Then we can use tensorflow to find
the pattern between q's and A's.
Once we do that,
we can use tensorflow serving to put
our trained chat Bot on a server,
then have it update and retrain as it
receives new questions so it gets better
over time.
We can sell our solution to small online
schools that need more support for
their students, for our initial
clients and scale up from there.
Adding new features like automated
grading and even full on AI teachers.
Are you hyper yet?
You should be.
There are three things to
remember from this video.
The open source tensorflow library
offers a huge suite of tools that offer
developers an end to end pipeline
to build profitable AI businesses.
To build a profitable business,
pick an industry and find where a solution
that uses data could solve a problem
for ideally other businesses and start
small focus on profitability in a very
small niche and scale up from there.
Please subscribe for more programming
videos and per now I've got to grow a
business,
so thanks for watching.